foreign
comes from Ben in Florida he writes I
understand tipping 20 at a restaurant
when I'm dining in but am I obligated to
tip at a restaurant when I place a to-go
order there's no service provided other
than making a meal and I drove to pick
it up am I wrong here I'm curious what
your thoughts are with how crazy tipping
has become culturally
this has been all over Dave as self
checkouts now have tipping screens so
everyone's really funny bits on this we
had there's Social Media stuff George
Campbell look him up on social media
making fun of the uh spin tip move where
they spin the thing around at the fast
food joint and ask you to tip well and
it's always the uh just gonna ask you a
question like you don't know what the
question is yeah you know it's always
the other one scenario the other one I
saw the other day I was cracking up and
you we teach generosity let's just be
clear okay one of the reasons to get
your money together is to be crazy
generous but the other one was it's like
I go into this guy said I go into a
grocery store and they're like do you
want to add ten dollars for Hungry
children he's like no I want this Mega
Corporation to pay for Hungry children
I'm not adding ten dollars it's like oh
everywhere you go I'm checking out
buying a dog collar do you want to help
dogs oh yeah they have it on online
check out I mean PetSmart's got a thing
right everywhere they got a done for ten
dollars for starving something and uh
listen I I totally believe in taking
care of pets I totally believe in taking
care of uh Starving Children and all
that but I don't do it at the uh when
I'm checking out I'm more thoughtful
with my generosity and much larger with
my generosity than that now having said
all that the the spin move is this is
kind of Middle Ground here on the to-go
order
I think dining in I'm outrageously
tipping valets I'm outrageously tipping
a they're out in the rain the sun b
they're driving my really nice car and I
don't want Ferris Bueller's Day out I'm
outrageously tipping okay so uh all
right so now we've covered that stuff I
believe in tipping I always leave a a
really nice large spill as a tent on the
uh bed when I leave a hotel room that's
sitting right there on the end so it's
obvious what it was for the uh the
person that's nice enough to clean up
that room for me and I didn't have to
make my bed that day life is pretty good
so uh you know I tip I believe in
tipping there were some physical
Services tipping at a fast food joint no
tipping at the Starbucks line no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
tipping your driver sure
tipping your Bellman you better yeah
this guy yeah big time be outrageously
generous with tipping this one is kind
of in the middle it's not really fast
food
it's a dine-in nice restaurant or a
semi-nice restaurant that would have
given you the opportunity to tip were
you to have sat down and had a waiter
which you did not have but sometimes
they assign a waiter a host or a person
to work this table yes and that's the
the caveat here is there is physical
effort involved with packaging up all
your stuff making sure the order is
right adding the utens all of that but
it's not the same level of service as I
walk up today 17 times to make sure he's
got water make sure he's got what he
needs you know show them the menu
recommended some wine whatever it is so
I don't see it in the same category I
don't tip 20 on to-go orders unless it
was a giant group order catering they
out served me they were amazing but
generally it's a buck or two maybe ten
percent on a to-go order and some people
actually force it now there's one
restaurant in town that I get to go
orders from they have a 10 service fee
built in to go orders so businesses are
just going we're going to force a
gratuity which I'm not a fan of
but they can do what they want to do
participate they didn't force you to
shop there no I chose to still eat all
right all right so yeah that's the
caveat uh but I don't like the guilted
generosity or the force Generations
that's the thing with the starving
children in the grocery store thing yeah
so should you um I think it's a nice
thing to do and I think it's a great
reason to get your finances in order to
just to be able to do that but if you
feel guilted into it I wouldn't do it
out of guilt
I'm gonna make eye contact while I spin
the screen around and go custom tip 0.00
there we go that's the way
Savage but I got hate on this Dave
because we posted and all the comments
they're saying I work in the service
industry and I can't believe you don't
tip 25 work in the service industry if
you work in fast food
let me help you with this you work in a
fast food place that's not the service
industry
service Industries where you provide
service not where you hand food over the
counter that someone else cooked no that
I'm sorry you're a cashier if you work
in the fast food where does the line end
Dave our grocery stores are we going to
start tipping I mean they bag our
groceries if the guy takes under my car
those guys absolutely we're getting a
tip absolutely but just for scanning it
through the checkout line I don't think
it qualifies as gratuity no
and uh I was in uh Mexico and went to a
nice
uh they have a whole different set of
Customs right uh a nice grocery store a
high-end grocery store so to speak if
you can get that right in your head but
um it's the whole thing this is not a
this is not this you know it's a nice
play and they don't they don't do bags
you bring your own bag right and if you
don't have your own bag there's these
nice little
uh 90 year old Mexican ladies standing
at the end of the thing boxing the stuff
up in boxes that they brought from the
back and helping you out and I always
over tip those ladies there's just
something about them that just says big
money big money so yeah I want to do
that for sure this one I'm kind of going
to be 50 50. I got two thoughts on it
one is I don't want to be guilted into
anything I'm with you
um and B
um
I never
there's very few times I say never
almost never have I regretted being
generous
there's very few times I look back
unless I was guilted into it okay but
there's very few times I look back that
uh not counting because she didn't give
them that five bucks I
you know because they're in there
working and I'm just trying I'm doing
well God's blessed me why not you know
why not just be easy with it don't be so
that's God damn hard case but I do
resent this spin thing at the counter
and that is guilting I'm not doing that
I'm not doing the ten dollar thing I
skipped The Starving Children Hat on at
the thing I'll take care of starving
children through one of the Ministries
that the Ramsey Foundation that you've
added that we support that we vetted and
that we spend a whole lot more than ten
dollars I can promise you that and give
a whole lot more than ten dollars to
that so we're doing our part so to speak
but just not through
XYZ grocery store yeah and usually
there's a compliment as they spin it
it's hey uh you know love your hair you
ever get one of those that they never
say that to me I never get love your
hair that's sad if they tried that you'd
get a really big tip from Dave if you
try that never comes up no I it wouldn't
because that would not be real it would
be well there's an expectation if Dave
Ramsey wants a Smart ankle you love my
hair what do you oh yeah what's wrong
with you but do you feel pressure as a
public figure known for money in general
absolutely you know absolutely not going
to tell this story and winning when in
doubt if I'm going to give them a day
story it ought to be a good one that's
right so uh when in doubt God's made
giving me a lot of money to manage and
so I'm it's easy I don't that I don't
feel guilty about
um but I'm just very careful and
Sharon's like you way over tip and I'm
like yep yep and when I get to heaven No
One's Gonna Go nope you're not getting
in here because you over tipped you're
an overtipper it didn't work St Peter's
Never Gonna know you can't come in you
over tip Davis bad use of money because
it to me it's a form of generosity in
the appropriate situations this one gee
this one's right down the middle for me
so what what I'm gonna I'm trying to
visualize walking in because I don't do
this very often yeah like if we go to a
get a bunch of barbecue like you said a
big order that's what I'm saying like we
got a family reunion coming up Sharon
will send me up to the barbecue place
and I'm picking up like boxes of crap
you know pickles like 80 gallons of
pickles you don't gotta go to these
parties all this stuff man it's all well
there's a big family and so
when I'm doing that somebody has worked
their tail off on that yeah definitely
going to jack that one up so but if
Dave's passion I don't know a single
person's order that's generally my
situation personally do that so I don't
know how I would react I'm probably when
in doubt they'll be generous you never
messes up but is it a mandatory cultural
thing no is it a generosity move if you
do it yes